[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'analyse sur Public Sénat
90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité avec pour commencer un débat
100% politique l'actualité de ces
dernières heures passées au crible de
nos experts et notamment le clash entre
Cyril Hanouna et Louis Boyard le député
et les filles vient d'annoncer qu'il
portait plainte je déposerai également
une plainte contre Cyril Hanouna qu'on
soit député ou non un présentateur n'a
pas à insulter quelqu'un en direct pour
avoir critiqué le propriétaire de sa
chaîne
commission d'enquête hypocrisie de nos
élus dérives de la politique spectacle
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder tout à
l'heure et puis dans notre second débat
volontairement décalé vous le savez de
l'actualité du jour on analysera avec
quelques semaines de recul la brouille
franco-allemande un conseil des
ministres communs reporter des choix
militaires allemands atlantistes indus
au Macron Scholt moins harmonieux le
moteur de l'Europe a des ratés on vous
expliquera pourquoi et vous demandera si
c’est pour longtemps mais d'abord mais
d'abord cette annonce de Gérald Darmanin
cet après-midi au moins 44 des migrants
de l'océan Viking seront expulsés les
autres vont attendre un éventuel asile
politique ou partir vers d'autres pays
européens Cécile Sioux et Samia de chien
depuis 4 jours derrière ces tentent les
180 migrants de la chaîne biking sont
entendus par les agents de l'OFPRA
l'Office français de protection de
réfugiés il demande l'asile leur dossier
sont traités en accélérés et déjà une
quarantaine de demandes a été refusée
par les autorités françaises
pour les personnes qui se voient refuser
leur demande d'asile c'est 40 personnes
seront évidemment reconduites dès que
leur état de santé pour certains d'entre
eux le permettront dans leur territoire
national j'ai déjà pris à la demande de
la première ministre du président de la
République contacte désire avec mes
homogues étrangers pour que ces
reconduite à la frontière puisse se
faire évidemment dans les temps les plus
court possible retour dans leur pays
d'origine pour certains d'autres pour le
moment ont pu quitter la zone d'attente
normalement fermée car comme le veut la
loi au-delà de quatre jours un juge des
libertés est appelé à statuer sur le
maintien des migrants dans ces zones
pour les quatre migrants concernés des
vis de procédure ont été constatées un
nombre respect du droit dont c'est
également à l'armée la sénatrice
marie-arlet Carlotti venu sur place pour
connaître les conditions d'accueil des
migrants malheureusement à travers la
petite fenêtre plastique on a vu un
monsieur complètement penché sur un
téléphone je suppose pour essayer
d'entendre la traduction donc là aussi
si ça me paraît compliqué de pour lui de
c'est terrible j'ai pu constater
effectivement qu'il n'avait pas de
recours aux avocats on leur dit mais il
le demande pas mais est-ce qu'ils savent
même qu'ils peuvent le demander les
signalements ici les informations sont
en français à part les Maliens très peu
par le français pour le moment 60
migrants peuvent demander l'asile des
Syriens des Soudanais et des érythréens
la France s'est engagée à accueillir un
tiers des demandeurs les autres seront
prises en charge par d'autres pays
européens
voilà la politique migratoire de la
France les dérives de la politique
spectacle avec l'affaire Hanouna mais
aussi les l'hypothèses d'un passage à
110 km/h sur nos autoroutes voilà les
trois thèmes que l'on va aborder dans ce
débat avec mes invités Catherine tricot
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directrice
de la revue regard j'accueille également
anne-charlen beezina bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes constitutionnaliste et
maître de conférence en droit public
Richard werlibois correspondant France
Europe pour le média Suisse Blic et
auteur de la France contre elle-même
publié aux éditions Grasset et Laetitia
cruppa éditoris politique bonsoir
Laetitia bienvenue à vous alors les les
vagues provoquées par l'accostage de
l'océan Viking en France continue de de
défaire les sur nos débats politiques on
parlera dans quelques minutes de la
réaction de l'ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur d'Emmanuel Macron Gérard
Colomb mais d'abord Catherine tricot
cette dernière actualité donc l'annonce
par le gouvernement de 44 des migrants
seront expulsés vers leur pays d'origine
je vais garder la sémantique maritime
c'est un coup de bar à droite
c'est pas très gentil avec des gentils
non plus franchement je veux dire ces
gens viennent de souffrir un martyr de
ils ont failli périr et la chose qu'on
en a à leur dire et à leur réservé comme
accueil c'est de leur dire on va vous
renvoyer chez vous c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ont pris des risques totalement fous
pour pouvoir s'en aller et si les ont
pris c'est parce que chez eux ce n'est
plus vivable je pense qu'on n'est pas du
tout en train de se préparer à la
transformation du monde qu'on est en
train de se mettre comme des autruches
la tête dans sable en disant que on va
s'en sortir comme ça en remettant les
gens dans les avions pour repartir en
les repêchant plus ou moins dans la
Méditerranée j'ai entendu ce chiffre
effrayant quand même il y a 50000
personnes qui sont mortes en
Méditerranée en 15 ans donc je veux dire
cette situation n'est pas du tout
possible on ne peut pas continuer de
gérer la question migratoire comme on la
gère de façon à mon sens aussi
bureaucratique et une humaine bien
Charlène benzina il y a évidemment tous
les enjeux politiques et on comprend
bien pourquoi aussi le gouvernement
français et et en difficulté ou alors
applique son en même temps à la
politique obligatoire ce qui est ce qui
est pas forcément simple mais voilà il y
a pas que la France dans beaucoup de
pays européens cette question migratoire
elle fait aussi progresser l'extrême
droite il faut voir cette réalité en
réalité cette question de la sécurité
associée finalement aussi à la peur de
l'étranger et donc à la au contrôle de
l'immigration c'est presque la l'une des
seules questions qui fait encore
complètement la bascule entre les
échiquiers politiques en France mais
aussi dans tous les pays de l'Union
européenne qui ont été frappés par ces
vagues de populisme parce que le le
nationalisme mais au sens vraiment au
pied de la lettre c'est à dire l'idée de
la priorité nationale etc gagnent du
terrain face à des états comme l'Italie
notamment qui sont en pression
migratoire très forte sur les finances
publiques sur aussi la manière de de
gérer une politique d'accueil et donc il
y a peut-être aussi des questions à
penser au niveau de l'Union européenne
c'est vrai que l'Italie a essayé de
jeter un petit peu cette bouteille à la
mer ces derniers temps avec son pour
politique bon très choisi mais qui au
fond essaye de remettre l'Union face à
ces responsabilités pour savoir comment
on va partager cette pression parce que
en effet la migration ne peut pas
considérer que c'est un phénomène
ponctuel exceptionnel pas du tout c'est
quelque chose qui dans les années dans
les décennies à venir va être un
mouvement du siècle et donc la question
de savoir comment gérer ça devrait
gagner évidemment à être un petit peu
dépassionné politiquement pour des
questions de gestion administrative etc
alors ensuite sur la manière dont 44
personnes vont être un peu immédiatement
reconduites c'est sûr qu'on est encore
sur l'émotion donc on a on a peut-être
un petit peu de mal à l'entendre mais
voilà c'est strictement l'application du
droit d'asile sur les sols nationaux et
procédures avec plus rapide que
d'habitude puisque bon alors on a quand
même encore les droits au recours qui
sont normalement préservés en tout cas
c'est le sens de la directive européenne
donc on va pas pouvoir faire ça mais
c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment que
l'idée d'accélérer les choses c'est
aussi une manière de préserver peut-être
le discours politique donc on reste
toujours dans cette extrême politisation
de la question Emmanuel Macron de
retarder justement le retour de celui
qui n'a pas le droit à l'asile dans son
pays donc il faut pas non plus quand ça
va trop vite dire bah ça va trop vite
exactement dire ça va c'est le sens du
nouveau projet de loi d'ailleurs l'idée
c'est pas se reproche moi ce que je
pense c'est que si on pense qu'on va
lutter de contre l'extrême droite et la
montée des craintes à l'égard de
l'immigration de l'autre de celui qui
arrive en faisant comme un fait Emmanuel
Macron c'est-à-dire en faisant un lien
dans son dernier interview entre
immigration et délinquance ou en se
faisant plus dur avec des délinquants
moi je crains que on ne fasse alimenter
en vérité cette crainte et c'est qu'on
fasse monter les idées que xénophobes
c'est-à-dire moi je ne crois pas que la
solution pour combattre l'extrême droite
soit de devenir plus dur à l'égard des
migrants plus dur à l'égard de ceux qui
viennent en France pour trouver une vie
meilleure parce que c'est pas la leçon
que vous tirez de ces derniers années en
France et en Europe absolument pas oui
c'est non ce que je pense c'est qu'on
est on est allé dans ce sens là qu'on a
aggravé la situation c'est justement
l'extrême droite ne cesse de monter
devant ses discours qui sont des
discours d'inquiétude à l'égard des
migration et dans lequel on fait droit à
la question identitaire d'une certaine
manière et je pense que c'est il faut
décrisper et que la France restera la
France combien même il y aurait des
migrants qui arrivent et en particulier
les 80 qui étaient dans Ocean Vikings
Richard Verly vous avez publié un
article sur ce thème dans pour le média
Suisse Blic pour lequel vous travaillez
vous vous pointez les contradictions
françaises pourquoi oui je crois que
cette crise de lotion Viking et le bras
de fer entre l'Italie et la France parce
qu'il y a ça en arrière-plan il a quand
même un immense mérite bien évidemment
ça se fait sur la douleur de l'accueil
mais il a il a un double mérite le
premier c'est que évidemment la réponse
elle est européenne c'est à dire il va
falloir peut-être va-t-on pas y arriver
mais il faut des règles d'asile qui soit
harmonisées en Europe sinon c'est pas
possible c'est qu'il faut que à un
moment donné et je vais un peu plus loin
c'est pas seulement les règles des îles
c'est aussi les règles d’accueil tout
simplement il faut pas qu'il il faut pas
que les migrants puissent jouer le terme
est mal employé pardonnez-moi mais il
faut pas qu'il y ait trop de différence
entre un pays et un autre sinon en train
de rêver tout parce que pas avec mélodie
ou la Hongrie
l'attitude de Georgia Meloni aujourd'hui
elle va permettre quand même d'avancer
et tout le calcul d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est de revenir au mois de décembre à
Bruxelles et de dire on a un problème
majeur il faut le régler d'accord
ensuite sur l'accueil précisément de ce
bateau là moi je suis un petit peu en
désaccord c'est à dire que on va de
toute manière vers un système comme ça
le vous savez que le mot pudiquement
employé c'est le mot des hotspots parce
qu'on veut pas parler de camp de transit
c'est le mot qu'on emploie notamment la
réalité c'est qu'on va arriver à un
moment donné à ce qu'il y ait des
centres de transit et que dans ces
centres de transit et bien il y ait des
gens qui ne soient pas acceptés sur le
territoire européen et qui repartent
immédiatement par contre moi ce que je
trouve si c'est le cas si ces gens sont
effectivement envoyés ce que je vraiment
problématique c'est qu'on ne parle pas
de compensation financière pour les
aider à rentrer parce que ça on en parle
pas on en parle en Allemagne on en parle
en Suisse on en parle dans notre prof
dans d'autres pays en France on en parle
pas si on renvoie ces gens et
personnellement je ne suis pas choqué
qu'on les renvoie il faut les renvoyer
dans des conditions qui leur permettent
en quelque sorte de réparer la douleur
de leur départ et de se réinstaller dans
leur pays d'accueil donc si on veut en
débattre il faut que le débat soit
complet et quand le ministre d'armane a
dit il suffit de les renvoyer là je
trouve c'est absolument malhonnête il ne
suffit pas des renvoyer un mot encore
le problème politique de fond c'est à
dire que ça en effet ça ça règle une
question humaine ce que vous dites mais
le problème politique de fond c'est
est-ce qu'on continue d'appréhender
cette question comme un péril pour la
France et pour l'Europe pour l'équilibre
de la France et de l'Europe ou alors on
se met devant la réalité qui n'est pas
mais je les vagues oui mais je pense que
je pense qu'on aura pas le choix je suis
désolé mais
l'ONU prévoit pour les 10 prochaines
années un milliard de gens qui vont être
commissariats au commissariat un
milliard
le milliard c'est d'abord le sud vers le
sud d'ailleurs c'est des pauvres qui
doivent gérer des pauvres et nous nous
la région la plus riche du monde on
pourrait pas prendre notre part de ce
train de cette réforme nous on ne
pourrait pas accueillir un million de
personnes enfin je veux dire l'Allemagne
l'a fait elle a accueilli on a accueilli
100000 Ukrainiens qui en a entendu
parler 100 000 Ukrainiens pas de
problème par contre 80 Eritrea maliens
etc ça nous pose un problème quelle est
l'arrière-plan que l'on a là-dedans
qu'est-ce qu'on a dans notre tête moi je
pense que franchement dans une majorité
des cas c'est là que c'est la question
de la religion et de l'islam dis donc
aux ongles sur la table
l'Ukraine c'était possible mais les
balles bien c'est pas possible
quand même l'Allemagne l'a fait et c'est
en train de marcher l'accueil des
Syriens on en parle d'ailleurs trop peu
parce que l'intégration se passe en
Allemagne mais l'Allemagne n'a pas
accueilli au même condition que la
France les contraintes parce que c'est
bien le mot qu'il faut employer imposer
au réfugiés qui sont arrivés en
Allemagne sont bien supérieures à ce
qu'on exigeant en France en terme
d'apprentissage de la langue en termes
de scolarité des enfants etc etc non non
je juge pas
d'intégration je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ça mais je pense pas
évident
je pense qu'en on peut pas nier non plus
le caractère hautement politique de
cette question et même le le droit et
l'obligation pour un état de gérer sa
nationalité et donc le choix des
personnes qui habitent son territoire et
comment à quelle condition donc je pense
que après partir sur l'idée que
l'humanitaire l'emporte et que donc du
coup une intégration automatique se
fasse il y a quand même un hiatus à mon
avis qui
parce que le temps file parce que il y a
aussi dans ce débat une parenthèse entre
guillemets de politique intérieure qui
est quand même assez intéressante à
analyser puisque c'est à la fois cette
Ocean Viking une arme pour les opposants
d'Emmanuel Macron et peut-être aussi
pour son ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
tiens Gérard Collomb qui déclare on
accueillant je le cite un lotion Viking
on ouvre une brèche il faut pourtant lui
d'un des premiers soutiens d'Emmanuel
Macron il faut s'en souvenir il sort de
sa réserve nous dit le point pour
alerter de ce qu'il juge comme un
tournant dans la politique migratoire de
la France évidemment cette pique signée
Gérard Collomb elle est immédiatement
utilisée par les oppositions
parlementaires un exemple la
porte-parole du rassemblement national à
l'Assemblée cet après-midi
madame la Premier ministre vous ne
faites rien les centres de rétention
explosent vous expulsez personne nos
policiers travaillent dans le vide d'une
justice qui ne suit plus les préfectures
débordent tandis qu' ancien ministre est
préfet des fils dans les médias pour
décrire l'inimaginable votre politique
c'est accueillir et répartir le
rassemblement national lui veut secourir
et reconduire alors on va pas commenter
le rassemblement national du soyez
intéressant de voir comment c'était déjà
intégré l'ancien ministre dans une pique
parlementaire Catherine tricot le RN il
est là où on l'attend mais l'alerte
lancée par Gérard Collomb est quand même
plus étonnante c'est un ancien baron
local du Parti socialiste
je pense que les évolutions politiques
de Gérard Collomb qui sont parallèles à
celles d'Emmanuel Valls ont profondément
déstabilisé la gauche et explique à mon
avis beaucoup de des difficultés que
rencontre la gauche et en particulier le
Parti socialiste c'est à dire que les
évolutions politiques de colon ou de
Valls sur les questions sécuritaires
identitaires d'immigration
mais je reste sur le le propos uncharen
bézina de l'ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur est-ce que ça ça vous a
surprise une certaine façon ça m'a
profondément interloqué notamment parce
qu'en fait je trouve que ça entre en
résonance avec un autre de ses discours
qui est vraiment un discours marquant
qui est celui par lequel il a quitté le
ministre de l'intérieur avec un donc
justement une passation de pouvoir qui
normalement à un moment assez formel oui
on a profité pour faire un espace de
discours sur la fracturation de la
France sur l'ENS sauvagement qui était
particulièrement notoires par rapport en
effet au bord politique dont il venait
et au fond dans ce discours là alors
après sincérité ou pas la question
politique se posera éternellement mais
elle était la teneur de ce discours elle
consistait à dire voilà la pratique du
terrain m'a changé et au fond c'est à
l'intérieur que je me suis rendu compte
de l'état de fracturation de violence
d'hypersensibilité de la société
française sur des questions que je ne
soupçonnais moi-même pas et c'était une
manière de souhaiter bon courage à son
successeur par rapport à finalement tout
ce qu'on découvre qu'une fois qu'on est
sur le fait donc je trouve que ça ça
prise de parole aujourd'hui entre
finalement en résonance avec cela c'est
à dire que profondément on a le
sentiment que d'un humaniste de gauche
alors j'imagine qu'il ne perd pas ses
valeurs mais il y a il y a une espèce de
modification par rapport à ce qu'il
aurait vu sur le terrain alors après
avoir ou pas il y a quand même aussi une
réalité dans ce qu'il dit c'est que
cette hacker de cet accueil de l'océan
vaking et en effet un tournant dans
notre politique migratoire alors moi je
suis jurison je considère qu'en effet
c'était pas vraiment un choix de la part
de la de la déjà de la France étant
donné que c'était un navire qui était
dans les eaux territoriales de la France
donc d'abord c'est pas vraiment un choix
par rapport à notre droit maritime et en
plus il y a ce pacte qui nous lie au
niveau européen mais je crois aussi que
on ne l'a pas fait en 2018 et le fait de
de franchir ce cap ouvre évidemment le
flanc à la critique politique donc il
entre finalement dans une évidence en
voilà déversant quelque chose qui qui
ressort de de son expérience est-ce
qu'après c'était le bon moment voilà la
question se pose politique
les propos de est-ce que c'est le dans
ces dossiers est-ce que c'est le PS qui
c'est dévoyé en quelque sorte ou alors
au contraire est-ce que c'est la société
française qui a évolué qui voit un islam
politique prendre de l'influence et donc
certains élus du PS qui sont obligés de
tenir compte non je pense que c'est
Gérard Collomb qui s'est trompé j'ai
excusez-moi Gérard Collomb la seule
logique qu'on trouve à son comportement
politique depuis 2017 c'est-à-dire le
moment où il avait soutenu Emmanuel
Macron et il en était devenu ministre de
l'Intérieur la seule logique c'était de
se faire relire à Lyon et ça a
complètement échoué donc voilà voilà
pour moi c'est la seule explication
c'est le seul fil rouge aujourd'hui que
veut-il à travers cette prise de
position est-ce qu'il veut régler
quelques questions du passé avec
Emmanuel Macron peut-être mais si
effectivement il avance la question des
hotspots si c'est ça je ne sais pas
quelle était la réalité mais il se
trompe à nouveau lourdement parce qu'il
faudra peut-être accepter un jour des
hotspot et il faudra peut-être accepter
que ces centres soit dans des zones
frontalières parce que la réalité que
vous souligner à savoir les vagues
migratoires il va falloir mettre en
place des dispositifs qui ne sont pas
toujours ni agréable à voir ni agréable
à entendre mais nos sociétés vont devoir
s'y faire donc sur ce sujet là pour moi
Gérard Collomb il a tout faux allez on a
attendu vos arguments
il a continué dans sa trajectoire mais
je pense qu'on s'abîme dans notre
humanisme si on accepte ça je pense que
franchement c'est nos valeurs humaniste
profondes qui enfin les hautes spots je
parle des spot je pense qu'on est on se
perd encore faut-il que ce soit faisable
d'ailleurs juridiquement zone
frontalière moi je comprends toujours
pas ce que ça veut dire parce que un
accueil migratoire européen il faut
qu'il se fasse en Europe donc il y a
quand même des questions voilà on est
joliment soit on trouve des territoires
à l'entrée sur les territoires européens
dans les autres frontières ont passé par
là
quel état d'être ce couloir
d'étranglement voilà question se pose
effectivement deuxième grand thème de ce
débat 100% politique de clash entre
Louis Boyard député les filles du
Val-de-Marne et Cyril Hanouna la semaine
dernière sur sur C8 l'animateur avait
traité le parlementaire qui voulait
parler des intérêts africains du groupe
Bolloré d'abruti de nazes de bouffons de
Toka entre autres noms d'oiseaux je vous
les ai pas tous cités Laetitia sur ce
dossier vous vous dénoncez l'hypocrisie
générale de la classe politique
exactement hypocrisie à tous les étages
tomates tous les politiques condamnent
les propos vous les avez cités de
l'animateur star de C8 mais aucun ne
veut boycotter son émission même pas la
France insoumise alors que vous l'avez
dit au début de cette émission le député
insulté a porté plainte et bien non la
France insoumise va continuer de défiler
sur le plateau de Cyril Hanouna et on va
écouter pour ça
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le on peut le dire
comme ça je ne sais pas si on peut le
dire comme ça je le dis gloubi boulga de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon hier soir en meeting
alors vous avez monsieur Hanouna mais je
vais pas lui jeter la pierre comme tout
le monde mais écoutez-moi il est juste
un visage découvert il a pas les bonnes
manières des autres qui sépare en
tortiller dans le poison et les
dentelles les propos oui est-ce que
c'était au pluriel ou est-ce que c'était
au singulier c'est une question grave
c'est un problème de conjugaison bien
sûr pas de racisme alors lui
je t'emmerde je m'en bats les couilles
etc voilà on parle comme ça un député
imaginez-vous l'inverse
imaginez-vous que ce soit Louis qui est
parlé comme ça qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
pas dit de l'insoumis en plus un jeune
mal élevé puis viens sûrement d'un
quartier pour parler comme ça
on peut suspect quand même malgré tout
quoi qu'il soit blond
enfin les Vikings
on faisait plus poli je ne sais pas si
vous comprenez quelque chose à cette
ligne de défense moi je ne vois pas
vraiment la ligne de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en tout cas même au même moment sur C8
l'animateur staff faisait son propre
débriefing en fait son auto débriefing
de son dérapage et du dérapage selon lui
du député et il rappelait qu'alexie
Corbière que Raquel Garrido qui a été
une de ses chroniqueuses vedettes et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon était ses amis alors
on va regarder de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique l'argumentation
est à peu près la même Marine Le Pen
s'exprimait ce matin sur France Inter
écoutez
d'abord je détermine pas les endroits où
je vais en fonction des des querelles
entre les anciens
intervenants de TPMP si vous voulez bon
déjà numéro 1 numéro 2 moi je considère
que l'insulte doit pouvoir être banni du
débat public mais ils n'ont demeure pas
moins que le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que se faire donner des leçons si
vous voulez de bienséance par la France
insoumise c'est quand même relativement
drôle parce que il passe leur vie eux à
insulter leurs adversaires politiques
voilà donc c'est dû en même temps
partout et en tant qu'avocate elle a
même ajouté que il existait en droit une
excuse à la provocation c'est à dire que
on peut être excusé parce qu'on a été
poussé à l'injure par quelqu'un d'autre
donc elle défendait par la même Cyril
Hanouna donc pas d'appel au boycott au
RN pas la peine chez les filles et au
sein du gouvernement pareil pas d'appel
oh boycott Thomas c'est comme les autres
on s'offusque des injures évidemment
mais on ne ferme surtout pas la porte du
studio de Cyril Hanouna on va regarder
parce que on a pas le droit pas de
diffuser cet extrait mais on va regarder
ce qu'a dit Olivier Vérand le
porte-parole du gouvernement alors là
aussi il faut s'accrocher à
accrochez-vous dans vos canapés par
choix je ne suis jamais allée dans
aucune émission de Cyril Hanouna c'est
un choix personnel pour autant je
n'incrimine pas ceux qui sont allés
parce qu'il faut toucher tous les
publics et peut-être qu'un jour j'irai
chez Cyril Hanouna s'il m'invite chacun
est libre de la façon dont il souhaite
communiquer avec les Français voilà
évidemment il ajoute que ça dépendra des
conditions qu'il faudra que ce soit dans
les bonnes formes etc et d'ailleurs
c'est pas loin de la ligne de l'ex par
paroles du gouvernement Gabriel attaque
qui m'avait confié personnellement que
lui il allait parce que Cyril Hanouna
proposait des formats politiques tout à
fait
traditionnel et classique où on pouvait
s'exprimer et que ça sonne limite était
les nouilles dans le slip c'est c'est
une super séquence aussi à revoir de
l'émission de Cyril Hanouna
c'est finalement c'est que toute se
presse sur le plateau de C8 depuis 2017
Gérald Darmanin il était pas plus loin
que le 20 octobre dernier il faisait une
des premières audiences de la TNT la
première je crois d'ailleurs pour la
première partie de l'émission et c'était
manuel Macron qui avait ouvert le bal
oui en 2007 lui aussi avec une séquence
qui est vraiment il faut revoir Cyril
Hanouna qui est devant la tour TF1 on
est juste après le débat de l'entre deux
tours avec Marine Le Pen Cyril Hanouna
va interviewer Emmanuel Macron et très
honnêtement on sent qu'il y a vraiment
un élan et un appel au vote pour le
candidat d'en marche donc le pouvoir a
selon les points de vue
institutionnalisés ou instrumentalisé
Cyril Hanouna et toute la classe
politique est hypocrite car personne ne
veut rater l'occasion d'être sur son
plateau la raison est le calcul
électoraliste et sont finalement très
simple tout se considère que le public
de Cyril Hanouna c'est finalement cette
France des gilets jaunes vous savez
qu'on a du mal à identifier mais qui
échappe aux politiques et donc le pari
des politiques qui vont sur ce plateau
c'est un avoir un boulevard avec une
communication sans intermédiation
journalistique pouvoir tout dire et deux
espérer convaincre les Français qui se
sont éloignés de la politique ou qui ont
un vote contestataire voilà et vous
aviez étudié vraiment tout ça dans votre
livre la tentation du clown publié chez
buchesse c'est ça voilà c'est le bon
éditeur c'est normal parce que ça
nourrit aussi votre analyse notamment la
déclaration de Gabriel Attal la
Catherine tricot sur l'hypocrisie je
commence par elle est fier et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est-ce qu'il y a effectivement
une part d'hypocrisie puisque ils y vont
ils y sont allés Raquel Garrido était
chroniqueuse Louis Boyard aussi
d'ailleurs il faut il faut pas ça il
faut pas l'oublier moi je pense en effet
que pour l'instant ils ont pas décidé de
pas y aller parce qu'il continue de
penser que c'est le lieu pour pouvoir
toucher un public qui ne peuvent pas
toucher par ailleurs qui ne viendra pas
dans les meetings et qui ne va pas
regarder les les émissions que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon fait sur sa chaîne Youtube
donc je pense que ils se disent que leur
manière de pouvoir toucher ce public là
ce que je crois c'est qu'il y a une
illusion de penser que dans ce public là
on fait de la politique à ce moment-là
moi je ne crois pas ça c'est-à-dire que
je crois que Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est
allé il l'a d'ailleurs dit le public de
Cyril Hanouna a voté pour lui dans une
forte proportion plus d'un tiers auprès
de la moitié ce qui est assez normal
puisque c'est un public jeune et
populaire c'est-à-dire on retrouve les
caractéristiques quand on regarde les
études qualitatives parce qu'en fait les
jeunes sont plus devant la télé
de télévision en tout cas voilà dans le
public de ces réunions on a une tranche
d'âge un peu plus jeune et donc
mes potes davantage Jean-Luc Mélenchon
que
le reste de la France je dirais mais je
ne crois pas que c'est parce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon va chez Cyril Hanouna
que le public jeune va être convaincu
par l'absence d'arguments développés et
payer c'est plutôt les discours et
l'expérience de la vie on se fait une
opinion politique par la vie que l'on
mène et pas simplement parce qu'on
écoute des bonnes blagues chez Cyril
Hanouna Richard Verly dans ce dossier
pour bien comprendre quand même il faut
rappeler les liens entre Cyril Hanouna
et la famille Bolloré ça avait un lien
financier qui ce chiffre en dizaines de
millions d'euros quoi oui alors il y a
un lien d'abord d'employés à employeur
puisque Cyril Hanouna est l'employé de
la chaîne C8 sur laquelle il officie et
cette chaîne appartient à la famille
Bolloré et il y a ça va plus loin
puisqu'il est partenaire dans la société
de production avec le fils l'un des fils
de Vincent Bolloré qui est je crois
Yannick Bolloré qui est un peu le
monsieur audiovisuel de cette famille
donc bien évidemment et par ailleurs
Cyril Hanouna a toujours dit que Vincent
bollor est un ami personnel et qu'au
moment où il avait des traversées du
désert médiatique Vincent Bolloré
l'appelait au téléphone et était l'un
des rares à prendre de ses nouvelles
donc oui je pense vraiment que Cyril
Hanouna pense qu'il appartient à la
famille Bolloré et que dans sa dans son
outrance il y a une réaction familiale
je défends les miens d'ailleurs il le
dit quasiment la main qui me nourrit
mais ça va au-delà c'est je défends les
miens je défends mon clan non ce qui est
dans cette affaire il y a deux choses
d'abord quand même le député évidemment
a été insulté c'est intolérable etc mais
il est évident que il veut le clash
qu'il obtient et qu'il persiste dans le
clash faire qu'il sait en mettant la
question des intérêts Pékin de du groupe
Bolloré il sait il sait que ça va te
lâcher alors il est jeune et de toute
manière c'est intolérable ce qui s'est
passé mais il veut le clash il l'obtient
il aurait pu ça aurait pu s'arrêter
autrement un autre député aurait pu dire
aurait pu répéter écouter moi j'estime
que Vincent Bolloré a un gros problème
en Afrique et d'ailleurs il est en
procès pour ça mais puisque vous n'êtes
pas disposé à entendre je quitte le
plateau où je m'arrête là lui il ne
s'est pas arrêté il est revenu à
plusieurs reprises donc quand même
soyons un peu lucides aussi sur la sur
la petite manipulation non l'autre chose
c'est qu'il y a un gros problème c'est
que Cyril Hanouna c'est du
divertissement que maintenant on prend
pour du journaliste et ça c'est
absolument je dirais ça montre à quel
point
et que les politiques prennent pour du
journalisme parce que les politiques
finissent par assimiler son émission à
une émission de débat comme les autres
en moi j'avais regardé j'avais fait une
chronique d'emblic sur l'émission Face à
Baba avec Darmanin et je dois dire que
j'avais été j'avais trouvé cette
émission très bien menée sauf que le
problème c'est quand vous êtes politique
chez Hanouna vous êtes nécessairement
coupable à un moment donné ou à un autre
vous allez passer à la guillotine et ça
c'est terrifiant c'est que les
politiques les politiques qui vont chez
Hanouna vont à l'abattoir et on a
l'impression qu'ils aiment ça tout
simplement parce qu'il y a du public
devant la caméra il devrait quand même y
réfléchir à deux fois qu'est-ce qui vous
a frappé dans cette dans cette séquence
c'est que c'est très multifactoriel en
réalité on a affaire comme une affaire
qui ici est passionnante par rapport
d'abord aux questions qu'elle pose sur
les conflits d'intérêt c'est vrai que
l'arcom va être saisi l'ancêtre enfin la
nouvelle CSA justement sur ces questions
de lien entre ce qu'on appelle les
patrons presse la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel entreprise de presse
cette question de l'indépendance qu'on
peut avoir lorsqu'on détient les médias
et la liberté éditoriale qui est quand
même voilà un fleuron de la démocratie
donc ça c'est c'est important de le dire
on a une question en tout cas posée par
ce débat sur ce point qui est important
et qui doit être débattue et qui doit
être tranchée juridiquement il y a autre
chose qui moi me m'interpelle notamment
dans les propos tenus par Cyril Hanouna
à l'égard de Louis Boyard et on dirait
que toute la famille à la fille
finalement fait bloc avec ça c'est tu me
dois tout je t'ai fait alors je me
rappelle pas du Verbatim exact mais
l'idée est d'assumer assez ouvertement
que les médias deviennent les nouveaux
faiseurs de roi parce que Boyard
effectivement été chroniqueur dans les
émissions bon voilà c'est grâce à moi
que tu es là je n'ai voilà et notamment
en lien avec le respect de sa fonction
parlementaire en me disant je n'ai aucun
respect pour ta fonction parlementaire
étant donné c'est grâce à moi que tu
l'occupes donc je trouve que il y a
quand même quelque chose que là encore
là comme à mon avis va trancher qui est
qui est de l'ordre du conflit d'intérêt
entre politique et médias qui qui
implique une séparation des pouvoirs
alors certes pas traditionnel à la
montée mais sur laquelle quand même une
démocratie repose donc je crois que
c'est important quand même de ne pas
entendre ça dans dans une antenne de
grand public et puis il y a le troisième
point sur lequel je vous rejoins
largement c'est quel débat politique
voulons-nous pour notre avenir et quel
public voulons-nous aussi pour
l'élection de nos politiques parce que
alors faire un choix dans les publics
évidemment ça paraît tout de suite
discriminant et assez insultant bien sûr
pour le peuple français mais considéré
néanmoins que ce type de débat ce type
de niveau de discussion ouvre un
dialogue politique c'est quand même
avoir très peu de respect pour le débat
politique en tant que tel aussi donc il
y a quand même beaucoup de questions qui
se posent autour de comment en
démocratie maintenant on peut discuter
dans les médias voire même en s'opposant
depuis 1984 c'est Patrick Sébastien qui
est le premier reçoit Jacques Chirac
dans une émission de divertissement donc
ça fait 40 ans qu'on se pose cette
question et ça fait 40 ans que les
petits continuent d'y aller parce que je
voulais dit c'est un boulevard pour eux
il y a aucune intermédiation
journalistique et même s'ils sont prêts
à partir par le public c'est c'est
vraiment du terroriste tous les
communicants tous les spin doctor
conseillent à leur client aux hommes
politiques aux femmes politiques
viennent mais divertissement
l'art comme c'est de la rigolade
pardonnez-moi mais que une institution
qui est saisie sur quelque chose d'aussi
évident et qui à ce jour sauf erreur n'a
toujours pas pris position mais comment
on peut prendre cette autorité au
sérieux franchement alors il faut se
souvenir pour les défendre mais que
précédemment le CSA donc qui était la
version présente de harcom avait quand
même condamné
il y a des procédures il y a enfin bon
voilà c'est long c'est sûrement trop
long mais ça peut aboutir des
condamnations il y avait eu interdiction
de de d'écran publicitaires avant et
après l'émission et ça avait écouté très
cher à ces 8 je vais vous redonner à la
parole dans un instant parlant pardon
Catherine mais je voudrais que on
revienne sur le la plainte alors Louis
Boyard a porté plainte Thierry la Nouna
aussi pour diffamation Louis Boyard en
plus de sa plainte il a demandé
l'ouverture d'une commission d'enquête
relative à la concentration des médias
et plus spécifiquement sur les
financements de l'Empire Bolloré je
propose à Audrey Vedas de nous rejoindre
tout de suite sur ce plateau bonsoir
Audrey bien bienvenue bon le souci c'est
que ça a déjà été fait ici au Sénat oui
pas plus tard que l'an dernier et quand
Louis Boyard entend auditionner Vincent
Bolloré bah ça aussi ça a déjà été fait
par le Sénat c'était dans le cadre d'une
commission d'enquête sur la
concentration des médias lancé à
l'initiative du groupe socialiste au
Sénat pour voir si cette concentration a
un impact sur la démocratie alors on a
vu défilé devant les sénateurs une bonne
partie du CAC 40 propriétaire de médias
Bernard Xavier Niel Martin Bouygues et
Vincent Bolloré bien sûr même si c'est
patron était censés répondre sous
serment il y a des moments on est un peu
resté sur notre faim on va écouter dans
un instant Vincent Bolloré sur le rôle
qu'il pensait avoir sur les médias qu'il
dirigent et dans la foulée la réaction
de David Assouline le rapporteur PS de
cette commission que j'ai interviewé ce
matin
je n'ai pas le pouvoir
de nommer qui que ce soit l'intérieur
des chaînes voilà je peux proposer je
peux donner mon avis je peux dire ne
pensez-vous pas que voilà et si
quelqu'un n'a pas envie de le faire il
le fait pas et j'ai 4 5 6 7
personnes qui sont toutes connues et
connus pour leur force que si est
considère c'est pas bon pour le groupe
ne le feront pas il se cache derrière
son petit doigt parce que effectivement
d'abord la terreur qui impose vous voyez
bien si on critique ce qu'il a son nom
même ont subi des foudres effroyables
mais vous pensez bien que les salariés
sont un peu tétanisés donc il y a une
auto-censure mais même il y a eu des
moments d'intervention connus mais
personne ne veut vraiment dire des
choses malgré cela le sénateur pense que
l'état des lieux sur l'empire Bolloré a
été fait et bien fait est-ce qu'il
appelle tout de même à légiférer oui
c'était d'ailleurs l'une de ses
préconisations dans son rapport il y a 8
mois n'a pas donné lieu pour l'instant
une proposition loi pourtant la loi de
référence sur la concentration des
médias date de 1986 il serait peut-être
temps de la remettre un petit peu à jour
ça pourrait changer la France insoumise
a fait savoir tout à l'heure qu'elle a
eu qu'elle allait utiliser une de ses
niches parlementaires à l'Assemblée
nationale pour faire une proposition de
loi visant à mettre fin à la
concentration dans les médias et dans
l'industrie culturelle mais en attendant
vous en avez parlé David Assouline
appelle LARCOM le nouveau CSA il demande
qu'on aille plus loin oui pour des
amendes mais il faut même aller plus
loin quand il y a des dérapages écoutez
on va punir avec une amende lourde des
fois ça a été 200000 euros mais lui paye
à ce moment-là il paye quand il veut
liquider une rédaction il paye des
départs
etc donc il faut un moment donné quand
il y a autant de choses se poser le
problème du conventionnement même de
chaque qui accepte de façon récurrente
et comme l'inéditoriale de contrevenir à
la convention qui est passée avec
l'arcom pour avoir le droit d'émettre et
avoir une fréquence voilà c'est c'est
très clair donc je pense que et il y a
la modification de la loi mais il y a
aussi à appliquer à la lettre et de
façon plus ferme la loi pour l'instant
pour la mise à jour l'art comme c'est
contenté de confirmer qu'elle avait été
saisie et que la séquence serait
analysée merci beaucoup Audrey
effectivement ça risque de prendre un
petit peu de temps on l'a bien compris
Catherine tricot voulait intervenir je
vous donne la parole pour terminer
est-ce que vous imaginez les les
parlementaires
attaquer au si frontalement un groupe
voilà propriétaire de canal du JDC de
Paris Match enfin bon je peux je
pourrais rallonger la liste hein
on peut pas se retrouver avec quand même
l'essentiel de la grande de la presse
française de la presse privée appartient
à 9 capitaines d'industrie ça ce n'est
pas possible on est dans une situation
absolument humoristante plus cette
concentration c'est non seulement on a
l'essentiel des médias qui appartient au
grand groupe et qu'en plus on a un
certain nombre qui détiennent tout donc
c'est moi je suis tout à fait d'accord à
ce que vient de dire le sénateur à
souligne c'est-à-dire qu'il y a quand
même une question
C8 les le passage de ces 8 c'est une ça
appartient à la France veut dire les
ondes sur lequel C8 émets c'est une
propriété nationale qui leur est
octroyée selon un cahier des charges il
faut faire enfin je veux dire on peut
pas continuer d'accepter que les choses
soient à ce point
Foulées du pied et cette concentration
mais moi je pense que la question d'une
façon générale l'idée que si ça vous
appartient alors vous devez vous taire
me paraît une position de la part des
journalistes qui travaillent enfin en
l'occurrence c'est un animateur mais qui
travaille sur cette chaîne voilà c'est
la main qui me nourrit donc on en dit
rien ce n'est pas et c'est ça que je
trouve regrettable dans ce que dit
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est qui dit en gros
les journalistes c'est ce qu'ils font
par tout ailleurs je ne crois pas que ce
soit le cas je ne crois pas que la
France est un monde journalistique qui
se soit complètement plié et qui ne
veuille plus enquêter qui ne veuille
plus parler des problèmes qui fâchent
leur patron de presse je pense que
d'abord on a une presse non privée quand
même en France il y a quand même un
service public qui est non négligeable
et voilà nous sommes sur une chaîne du
service public donc c'est fort bien et
par ailleurs ce que je pense c'est que
cette
ça jette une eau propre sur l'ensemble
de de des journaux et des journalistes
qui
pour pouvoir continuer de s'exprimer
mais l'idée que si ça vous appartient
alors on se tait c'est un problème pour
les journaux mais c'est un problème
global c'est à dire que donc les
salariés n'auraient pas le droit d'avoir
un avis sur ce qui se produit dans leur
entreprise sur la manière dont ça se
produit c'est-à-dire qu'on ne va pas
réussir à faire une France moderne si la
logique c'est si ça t'appartient tu te
tais non mais
qui est passionnant qui est celui des
lanceurs d'alerte de la protection des
lanceurs d'alerte et des médias qui
relayent les informations des lanceurs
d'alerte ah il nous reste moins de il
nous reste 7 minutes tiens dans ce
premier débat et comme promis on va
parler maintenant des 110 km/h la
réaction d'Elizabeth borne à ce chiffre
un chiffre qui est issu tenait du
premier baromètre de la transformation
écologique réalisée par et là pour
Veolia 68% des Français
estiment que rouler à 110 km/h au lieu
de 130 sur l'autoroute est acceptable
voilà ce qui ce qui a été dit et
évidemment
le soir sur BFM TV la première ministre
a réagi quand vous dit allez prudente
je pense en effet que quand on passe de
130 à 110 km/h on réduit de 20% sa
consommation et du reste dans le cadre
du Plan sobriété qu'on a présenté il y a
quelques semaines pour les
fonctionnaires de l'État on leur a
demandé de limiter leur vitesse à 110
km/h quand ils utilisent des voitures de
service toute fonction de là à imposer
aux Français je pense que ça n'est pas
la bonne voie et je pense qu'on a aussi
des gens qui ont besoin de se déplacer
sur autoroute et qui peuvent avoir des
contraintes de temps donc moi je pense
que c'est important d'informer on vous
dit on est sur les économies qu'on peut
faire en roulant moins vite sur
l'intérêt que ça peut présenter pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais on peut pas fonctionner à
coup d'interdiction
Vézina la première mise elle est en
l'entendante tout à l'heure je me suis
dit elle marche sur des œufs pas en
jaune comme les gilets jaunes vous voyez
ce que je ce que je veux dire ça pousse
quand même une petite question de
cohérence politique oui
alors ça je ne vais pas
m'avancer mais je crois vraiment qu'en
effet ce qui est reproché à cette
première présidente d'Emmanuel Macron et
on s'oriente malheureusement à mon avis
dans la même pente sur la deuxième c'est
un sens de la communication politique
qui a tendance à infantiliser finalement
le peuple c'est-à-dire que et la France
n'est malheureusement pas du tout isolé
dans ce dans ce concert européen c'est
qu'on a un petit peu de mal à revenir
dans le normatif c'est-à-dire on impose
on choisit voilà on mesurera
l'acceptabilité ensuite on explique
aussi voilà alors là c'était le grand
fleuron d'Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs je
vais faire de la pédagogie d'accord mais
en effet c'est vrai que ici on se rend
compte que on n'ose plus vraiment
politiquement imposer quelque chose
on va dire qu'elle responsabilise les
Français puisqu'elle dit c'est à vous de
c'est à vous de faire le geste c'est à
vous d'y aller pas besoin d'une norme du
Nouvel An c'est un discours de l'ordre
de l'incitation de la préparation or on
sait bien que c'est pas nécessairement
là-dessus qu'on fera des économies
d'énergie soit on veut de l'effectivité
soit finalement on veut essayer de
préparer le peuple en plusieurs temps
alors ça a l'air d'être là la politique
qui est choisi mais jusqu'à quand et
encore une fois moi je suis pas sûr que
ce soit forcément la bonne solution
futile on roule à combien sur autoroute
en Suisse et question sérieuses est-ce
qu'elle pouvait dire autre chose
Élisabeth borne alors qu'on a une
opinion française qui est je sais pas
quel est l'expression employée sur les
charbons ardents là voilà avec avec la
fin de la ristourne enfin les questions
de voiture en ce moment je suis pas sûr
que elle aurait annoncé aller je
j'annonce une loi 110 km/h ça ça aurait
profité à ce gouvernement sans compter
qu'elle a aussi les constructeurs sur le
dos parce qu'ils sont assez inquiets vu
que la sondiction électrique et cetera
bien sûr alors pour la Suisse c'est 120
km/h sur les autoroutes mais les
autoroutes sont moins larges qu'en
France donc il y a moins de voix en
général c'est des autoroutes à trois
voies alors qu'en France des fois vous
pouvez en avoir quatre assez souvent
suicider ou trois voies pour pour les
110 km/h vous avez tout à fait raison je
crois que c'est devenu le sujet de la
vitesse en voiture et de la voiture en
général est devenu un sujet explosif il
y a quelque chose qu'elle aurait pu
tenter moi j'avoue que j'aurais été
moins choqué c'est si elle avait proposé
un donnant donnant c'est à dire on est
en de sobriété on vous impose une
diminution de la vitesse mais on vous
propose une ristourne importante sur le
carburant et une baisse des impôts sur
le carburant ça ça aurait pu marcher
parce que les gens auraient pu imaginer
qu'ils y trouvent leur compte mais se
contenter d'imposer la vitesse alors que
par ailleurs l'État prend des taxes
énormes sur les carburants avec beaucoup
en dépendent je pense que c'est une
impasse c'est pas possible Catherine
tricot moi j'ai le sentiment que
l'inflation est plus efficace que que le
gouvernement pour accélérer la
décarbonation de mobilités oui en tout
cas c'est sûr qu'on ne peut pas se dire
que le gouvernement agit avec une une
ardeur
convaincante quoi c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait c'est en effet ils font des
discours ils parlent ils proposent ils
incitent ils vous propose de mettre des
pull-over mais enfin je veux dire
l'ampleur des problèmes auxquels on est
confronté va devoir il y a quand même un
problème de saut dans la pensée la
transformation qui n'est pas du tout
entamée et je pense que peut-être que ça
aurait fâché un certain nombre
d'automobilistes mais on a vu que 68%
des Français finalement semblait pouvoir
l'accepter oui mais alors c'est toujours
la difficulté d'un son qui est
intéressant c'est une étude une étude
mondiale qui a été menée par l'appareil
là c'est 25 pays ça représente 60% de la
population mondiale et sans toi 68 % de
mémoire des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de la planète donc c'est une étude
ambitieuse l'inquiétude des Français à
l'égard du réchauffement climatique elle
est sans cesse croissante on a tous en
tête et je vous interrompre
Philippe 90 80 km/h est-ce que ça
provoqué derrière pas porté chance mais
d'abord c'était pas hier c'était il y a
4 ans ensuite il y a eu la convention
pour le climat et ça faisait partie des
propositions qui étaient sorties de la
convention pour le climat qu'Emmanuel
Macron s'était engagé à appliquer qu'il
n'a pas appliqué et depuis on ne cesse
de voir l'inquiétude et la jeunesse en
particulier je dirais Emmanuel Macron il
est obligé de faire des selfies avec des
blagues avec des tresses et je sais pas
quoi pour se prendre en Greta tomber
pour essayer de convaincre les jeunes
qu'il agit parce qu'il n'agit pas parce
que les gens et notamment dans la
jeunesse on a tous des jeunes jeunes
jeunes autour de nous les 15-25 ans mais
ils sont vraiment alors il y a ceux qui
sont sur les charbons ardents pour
savoir s'ils peuvent encore rouler à 130
mais il y en a plein qui sont sur les
charbons ardents pour savoir dans quel
monde ils n'ont pas le permis mais qui
se demandent dans quel monde décide de
pas le passer aussi parce que ils sont
urbains et parce que ils en ont pas
besoin bien sûr dans quel monde dans
quel monde vont-ils vivre ils sont très
inquiets de ça franchement le problème
des 110 c'est que c'était qu'une mesure
si elle était devenue avec un ensemble
de mesures pour le climat celle-ci
aurait été une parmi un package il y a
pas de paquet
c'est la seule mesure qu'on aurait
retenu
ce qui aurait provoqué des débats
politiques et je ne sais pas
un grand mage mais peut-être des
manifestations et un mouvement sur les
routes oui ce que je veux dire je suis
pas sûr parce que ce que je pense par
exemple que le début l'opinion a évolué
c'était peut-être je pense que la
question par exemple de optimiser parce
que il y a quand même tous les millions
de Français qui n'ont pas le choix que
de prendre leur voiture parce que il y a
pas les infrastructures de transport en
commun etc
Emmanuel Macron et d'ailleurs il y a une
fuite avant l'émission d'hier soir parce
que moi j'avais lu que les habitants
étaient contre les syndicats donc vous
voyez bien que là il tâtonne qui lance
des petits ballons décès pour voir où le
gouvernement va aller très vite un mot
chacun mais rapidement quand même le
problème des radars parce que si vous
mettez 110 km/h ça veut dire que vous
allez multiplier les contrôles ça veut
dire que les automobilistes vont penser
que l'État s'enrichit à nouveau sur leur
dos donc c'est une très mauvaise
mayonnaise en effet c'est la question
aussi de la faisabilité technique du
contrôle de tout ça parce que on impose
déjà au fonctionnaires mais encore une
fois faut-il le contrôler et ça pose
encore une suspicion sur les recettes
l'un des enseignements qui est
passionnant de ce baromètre de la
transformation écologique c'est que
alors là c'est pas les Français c'est la
population voilà les humains la
population mondiale est prête à faire
des sacrifices à condition qu'ils soient
expliquées et qui soit partagé oui voilà
il soit juste perçu comme juste on va
conclure là-dessus merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat à évidemment dans cette dans cette
émission et sur public